Jordan Klepper here at the opposition
we're taking a well-deserved break this
week because sometimes the most
productive thing you can do is take some
time off to think to pray we're not the
only ones taking a breather the NRA has
also gone completely silent since
yesterday for some I don't know unknown
reason these guys love to talk tweet
bait aggressively attack and especially
donate to some of our favorite members
of Congress like these folks love these
guys now I'm glad you guys are taking a
break you work so hard you do so much I
mean honestly how do you have time to
sleep
I mean seriously NRA how do you sleep at
night how with everything that's
happening how do you even sleep our show
returns on Tuesday and you know maybe
the NRA will be back tweeting by then -
you hear that NRA as far as I'm
concerned you guys are a bunch of see
you next Tuesday's the fight continues
you you a deep state operative is sent
by George Soros to take away my second
Amendment rights and force-feed me soy
burgers No
well then prove it click and subscribe
and join the opposition now